if you've got money to spare but no time
to waste
there's only one way to fly a Cessna
Citation ten it's meant with one purpose
is to create the fastest plane that is
not operated by the US military yeah it
feels like a fighter jet
it is Brad Stewart is a turnaround guy
for TPG Capital his current post CEO of
EXO jet people who tend to fly this
plane tend to want to go three or four
hours more they're tending to fly for
business versus leisure they tend to be
men and women who either own their own
company or who run a company who just
valued that incremental 30 or 45 minutes
you know being home late but getting
some sleep so they can be there when
their kids wake up in the morning is the
difference between making that job work
and not work a citation ten tops out at
seven hundred miles per hour the ride
time from Teterboro to LA for hours on
the dot charter cost twenty-five to
thirty thousand dollars compare that to
commercial six hours in first-class will
still cost you a couple of grand if you
have a little more time and want to even
push your ride you could also try the
bombardier challenger challenger to me
is the Escalade of private jets if our
other plane the citation ten is the
Ferrari it's built throw a larger load
it's a great plan to go to the mountains
spacing to go to the to the islands in a
challenger you're looking at about five
hours from New York to LA it cost a
little bit more than a citation 10% of
the 1% can truly justify and afford this
experience and fit it into their
lifestyle mostly its CEOs of people own
businesses finance years they also are
individuals who tend to have a net worth
of 30 to 40 million or more and an
annual income of 4 or 5 million or more
EXO jets business is business
private jet biz tends to track the SP
perhaps no surprise then with stocks
near record highs Stewart says business
is great feels low economy is good the
Golden Age of private aviation